love in a sense where you know someone
needs to be loved by someone whether
that's your mom or your dad that's
loving you
like they need love but in terms of like
me giving love to someone then yeah not
everyone can just get my love because my
love isn't just something that i'll just
be throwing out i'm very like protective
of it
for me i also agree with you i'm don't
remember your name um yeah not everyone
deserves love because some people are
just too evil too wicked too spiteful
and they don't have pure or good
intentions or they try to manipulate you
or deceive you or like love for me and
then
change into a completely different
person so no not everyone deserves love
um so i kind of half agree with the
thingy like love in a relationship
no but loving a family i think it should
be but at the same time that's more like
responsibility than than actual love
because there are parents out there who
generally just don't love their kids so
it's not it's not um what's it called i
don't know that word where it's like you
have to do it or whatever but yeah so i
would say no in relationships
yeah um
does everyone deserve love no but people
do everyone deserves acknowledgement and
like just
making you feel like you exist to
someone
like it doesn't have to be full on love
but at least appreciation
do you feel like homeless men are
appreciated
some of them i've seen some of them
maybe by and large like
in general
they probably were at some point in time
yeah you think so
yeah
i i'd say exceptional like vets or
something like that but but other than
that
it's really hard to look like oh this
person doesn't pay money into the tax
system this person doesn't you know that
like it's it's very hard to look at um
it's cruel i'm not saying that you
should but i think general people just
walk past and think like what are you
doing well i think when you say
acknowledgement it's from a woman's
point of view because we're used to
getting attention we've gotten attention
from like the what the day we were like
13 14 whenever you started to like
become womanly
but like there's a large portion of men
that like don't get attention ever
um i wouldn't say just like from being a
woman i'll just say just
like being human in general because like
the word the world has become very like
focused on image and social media where
people have lost a sense of humanity so
in that sense well no i i understand
what you're saying but i just think it's
not reality like if you walk past a
homeless man you're not going to give
him any attention or pay him any mind in
general you might give him some change
or food you might even a look is an
acknowledgement
like you just you looking away and
acting like you don't see that person
then that's you just you don't care
basically okay what do you think um
in relationships yeah love doesn't
really work but for family love is very
important
quick question as well yeah um so um
i've got your name dionte dionte just
repeat what you said um about spiteful
um i don't even remember but
about the most people deserve love
you're like no no yeah like some some
people
they're spiteful or wicked like they
they don't have good intentions in their
heart or they go out to destroy other
people because of their past experiences
or because of their trauma or because of
they've been hurt by a female or family
member or whatever else and in order for
them to move forward they don't move
forward with like their best foot or i
was going to say isn't that like a lot
of girls
i i just see baby mom
bladder to my head right now really
can you can you um give like expand that
because i don't really understand yeah
like the point of view that you're about
for manipulative yeah all these other
negative words yeah and when when you
say these words i think about a lot of
women like you said women have sex
trauma
um women get spiteful because men treat
them as certain et cetera et cetera they
don't enter new relationships to the
best intentions right because you don't
have to work on yourself because
everything's been given to you yeah
especially if you're an attractive woman
so i feel like all those words just put
out there yeah describes a lot of women
in today's system but i feel like i
don't know if you recall the question
was does everyone deserve love you said
no yeah and then you describe those
words that's um that's why i said that
sounds like a woman to me i just want to
get your face um okay well um so would
you say bitter baby mamas don't deserve
love um
some don't let's be let's be real like
some don't because um
if you're going if you're going to be
really honest with yourself um which a
lot of people aren't um they if we're
talking specifically about baby moms
like a lot of baby moms or baby fathers
um use the child as a um form yeah as a
as a porn in order in order to get
certain things from the ex-partner in
order to make a point and stuff like
that so like i do understand what you're
saying but i just feel as though like if
we're looking at it a lot deeper let's
just examine humanity rather than
examine oh yeah it's just the baby mom
because that's not always the scenario
in which we look at society so did
did the man make her crazy
or was she already like that because
you're the one who decided to have a
child with them so
why is it why do we owe it whenever we
put accountability on women we always
flip it and then blame the man
because it's just like oh so i said i
said bitter baby mamas so i didn't say
all baby mamas i i i
said bitter baby mama yeah and then you
and then your first reaction is well
what about the man yeah because it could
be actually
of the man you know men talk they say a
lot of stuff they feed you lies and you
know they make you feel a certain way so
therefore you might have to start acting
yeah but you don't have to act you don't
have to act psycho like that's a choice
like you chose to act psycho yeah but
it's mental health isn't it yeah
maybe the guy drove her to that point no
no i mean here's the thing i've been in
a toxic relationship before i don't do i
never did the crazy [ __ ] i see a lot of
these girls do on social media that's a
choice everyone reacts differently i
know but that's that's a choice that's
who you are that shows a lack of
character if that's how you react but
you don't like you know how much you
know you're not you're not a child like
you're you're a grown adult it makes
decisions it doesn't define who you are
just like when you have arguments in a
relationship or even with your siblings
it's absolutely there might be times
where you actually physically fight okay
it absolutely defines who you are the
actions that you choose when you are
angry absolutely define who you are if
if a man on the street got angry and
murdered somebody they wouldn't say oh
you didn't murder him it's okay you were
gonna happen so many times
but not to the judge the world doesn't
know you understanding and and the thing
is in life what pearl's saying is like
in life here the only thing you can
control like literally the only thing
you can control is yourself you you
cannot control anyone else their actions
what they do but you can control your
own actions no matter what so whatever
you do you have to take account
accountability for whatever you've done
if you get robbed on the street or you
get thing you've walked down a bad
street or you weren't looking out for
things you still have to take
accountability of your actions no one's
saying that the person who robbed you
isn't a bad person no one's saying the
men that didn't treat you right isn't a
bad person but at the end of the day you
still have to take accountability for
your own actions because that's the only
thing you can control
no without saying that no one's saying
you shouldn't take accountability
mental abuse is real so you don't know
what that could do to the brain yeah
like but you should be accountable then
leave
if you choose if you make a choice as an
adult to stay and then you act a certain
way because you chose to say that's your
own fault
and it says let me fit it let me finish
and it says something about your
character
it says something about your character
because if if it's in you to act crazy
then you're crazy
i i agree with you i everybody's got a
little crazy on them
i agree with you but then like i just
believe that like we can't hold everyone
to a particular standard when like you
were saying about like people having
mental health issues or like if somebody
has driven the person crazy like we all
know that women are more so emotionally
inclined so sometimes
yeah
stable unstable whatever you define it
as but i just feel as though like
sometimes we don't necessarily consider
like a man's influence on a woman and
going back to like one of your um
questions earlier about how is it that
when like a question like oh the baby
mum is brought up why do women always
flip it back on on the man and i feel as
though partially that's a defense
mechanism because us as women we're all
we always get the um
negative
um aspect of like what what life could
be or like some of our decisions and not
necessarily seeing what do you mean what
do you mean by the negative aspect um so
say for example um two people got
together they had sex they had a baby
um so we're speaking about the baby mom
however like the baby mom has been
making specific choices to restrict the
man from seeing the child or whatever um
sometimes we don't necessarily see that
there are reasons behind it some men are
just wackless some men are um yeah but
so are some women no no i understand
that let me kind of plan who's the
gatekeeper of six padding who's the
gatekeeper of sex the woman however men
are
but men can be manipulative men can sell
you a dream like
i i understand where you guys are coming
from but it's just like
like like i'm saying like a man is more
militant in in terms of their expression
oh a man a man does things to obtain um
sex women do things to obtain love so
the reason why a woman would have sex
with a man is because she feels as
though she will receive love from a man
the reason why a man says to a woman i
love you is because he feels that if he
says i love you he will receive sex from
her then he's the full in that situation
both of them not really because he gets
what he wants well so you don't get what
you want but you know what
that's the manipulation that's the right
situation that is the whole definition
is that manipulation that's a good
salesman
that's a good salesman i think think
about what my guy who was sitting there
earlier said when he said um before when
men used to get involved with women you
needed another man's approval in order
to get that
woman now women are screaming this i'm
independent i can do it all on my own
and you're making hella bad decisions
didn't you say well don't tell me i'm
making bad decisions like i just do what
the [ __ ] i want to do regardless of the
repercussions it has in society yeah for
me that's ludicrous that makes no sense
but also what you've got to remember is
that we live in like i think you were
saying earlier
not only that but like we live in a
hyper sexual society like everywhere you
look at women because of women i don't
know women we sexualize ourselves look
at i was just at carnival this weekend
the amount of half naked women i saw
that we sexualize ourselves it's not
just that if the guy looks at you the
man be naked you're gonna be like what
the [ __ ] you're looking at but your
cheeks are just in my face
yeah not that i agree with that 100
percent right
so if i told you as my girl here that
you can't wear certain clothes you're
gonna feel away controlling